el choque diplomático es un hecho
embajadoras convocadas versiones
cruzadas entre presidentes y
funcionarios que temen una posible
ruptura de las relaciones bilaterales la
atención va en aumento entre Colombia y
Guatemala la razón las acciones legales
que la fiscalía especial guatemalteca
anunció que iniciaría contra Iván
Velázquez actual ministro de defensa
colombiano y antiguo director de la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala respaldada por
Naciones Unidas la fiscalía especial
contra la impunidad emprenderá las
acciones legales correspondientes para
que respondan por sus actos ilegales
arbitrarios y abusivos el ex comisionado
de la comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala sisic y van
Velázquez Gómez y la ex funcionaria de
sisic Luz Adriana Camargo garzón
el fiscal Rafael currucciche apunta que
Velázquez debe responder por actos
ilegales arbitrarios y abusivos por la
recepción de sobornos en un expediente
corrupción que lo enlaza con la
constructora brasileña odebrecht sin
embargo curruc Chiche está en la lista
en el de Estados Unidos acusado de
obstruir investigaciones y desbaratar
casos de corrupción contra altos
funcionarios el caso contra Velázquez
provocó el rechazo de países extranjeros
como Estados Unidos y el repudio del
presidente Gustavo Petro quien catalogó
el proceso como una persecución y que lo
defenderemos
él seguirá siendo nuestro ministro
si Guatemala insiste
en apresar hombres justos bueno otros
nada tenemos que hacer fútbol
velas que lideró la investigación en
Guatemala que terminó con la división
del presidente Otto Pérez Molina en 2017
quien recibió una condena de 16 años por
corrupto el colombiano fue cesado de la
comisión internacional por decisión Del
mandatario Jimmy Morales que cerró la
entidad en 2019
en sus 11 años de funcionamiento la
comisión impulsó casos que implicaron a
680 personas entre funcionarios y
empresarios ganó 310 condenas y
desmanteló 60 redes criminales en un
país que ha obligado el exilio a cinco
agentes de la ley en tres años Por
investigar a